1 dürfen wir von der politik ja wohl
schon erwarten dass sie uns ihre politik
erklärt erst recht wenn sie das eine
sagt und dann selbst was ganz anderes
tut ja schauen wir auf das was die
regierung beschlossen hat in den
vergangenen stunden während in den
eigenen flieger in den regierungsflieger
wie wir jetzt alle gesehen haben keine
masken pflicht gilt hat sie die masken
pflicht beschlossen noch mal verschärft
für uns alle in urlaub fliegen also
verschärfte masken pflicht nämlich
künftig reicht nicht die medizinische
maske aus sondern ffp zwei masken nur
noch dann künftig während eben die
regierungsflieger masken frei sind ja
wie erklärt dass jetzt bitteschön der
gesundheitsminister ja was sagt ein karl
lauterbach zu dieser doppelmoral zu
diesem sonderregeln die wirklich kein
mensch mehr versteht was muss er
erklären der gesundheitsminister warum
der extrawurst für die regierung das
sagte
ja es ist ebenso es gibt eigene regeln
für die luftwaffe und für die
flugbereitschaft und die sind hier zur
zum einsatz gekommen und über diese
regeln hinaus hintern diejenigen die
mitgereisten noch getestet worden ja es
ist eben so
es ist eben so das ist wirklich alles
was dem gesundheitsminister dazu
einfällt zu dieser doppelmoral zu dieser
extrawurst das ist finden wir keine
antwort ja und das sind dünne worte in
der woche in der millionen deutsche
ohnehin schon den kopf schütteln über
eine regierung die von uns dass eine
verlangt und dann eben was ganz anderes
selbst tut
den aufschlag einer turbulenten masken
woche machen am sonntag kanzler olaf
scholz und sein vize robert habeck das
duo reist im regierungsflieger nach
kanada journalistentross inklusive doch
was fehlt und sorgt für mächtig ärger
keine maske wohin man sieht im
linienflieger gilt für otto
normalverbraucher nach wie vor die
masken pflicht beim regierungsflughafen
freiheit in diesem sommer regieren auf
höchster politischer ebene doppelmoral
und arroganz gemessen wird mit zweierlei
maß ist eben so könnte man das nicht
ändern gerechtigkeit schaffen könnte
[Musik]
doppelmoral und arroganz stadt klar
erkennbarer strategien in der deutschen
politik nicht nur im flieger auch in
bussen geht aktuell nichts ohne maske zu
spüren bekommen dass diese woche zwei
schüler sehen und zwölf jahre alt die
fliegen in der nähe von wismar
kurzerhand aus solch einem schulbus ihr
vergehen die maske sitzt nicht richtig
an dieser bushaltestelle müssen die
schüler aus gnade vor recht fehlanzeige
der vater eines jungen noch immer empört
in einem hoch
die regeln im schulbus strenger als im
regierungsflieger ist ebenso apropos
lauterbach an diesem mittwoch hat er
seinen großen auftritt
bundespressekonferenz
zusammen mit justizminister buschmann
verkündet er die neuen corona regeln für
herbst und winter ffp zwei masken
pflicht in fernzügen und ja auch in
flugzeugen masken und testpflicht in
kliniken und pflegeheimen und jedes
bundesland darf immer mal wieder für
sich selbst entscheiden erneut drohen
masken würmer und präge flut ist ebenso
in diesem sommer regieren auf höchster
politischer ebene doppelmoral und
arroganz gemessen wird mit zweierlei maß
ebenso herr scholz könnten sie da nicht
mal was machen ja
könnte ich
ja dann tun sie es auch bitte herr
scholz wir schauen jetzt aber noch mal
ganz genau rein in diese neuen krone
regeln die die regierung für uns alle
für den herbst und winter beschlossen
hat kurz zusammengefasst ich habe schon
mal raus maske maske und
pressekonferenz mit corona faust
begrüßung und maske
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach verkündet die details des
gerade von der bundesregierung
beschlossenen neuen
infektionsschutzgesetzes
eigentlich eine ganz simple aufgabe wir
wollen im kommenden herbst deutlich
besser für die pandemie gerüstet sein
dass das in der vergangenheit der fall
gewesen ist und ich rechne mit einer
deutlichen kroner welle im herbst aber
dass es hier nicht maßgeblich sondern
maßgeblich ist sollte eine solche welle
kommen müssen wir gut vorbereitet sein
folgende sieht das vom bundeskabinett
beschlossene gesetz vor bundesweit soll
ffp zwei masten pflicht in flugzeugen
und fernzügen gelten kinder zwischen
sechs und 14 jahren sowie personal soll
medizinische masken tragen dürfen in
kliniken und pflegeheim soll bundesweit
einem masken pflicht gelten wer zutritt
will braucht zudem einen negativen test
grundsätzlich nicht schlecht also alles
junge leute schützen kann warum findet
es nicht schlimm wenn die maske immer
tragen muss auf dem flug bin jetzt
deutlich als geflogen war kein problem
ich sowieso eine auf also
vollkommen überzogen und länder die
haben zustand nicht so in der sache wir
sehen das viel lockerer und
ja also ich habe auch keine lust drauf
weist schon nervig ist mit einer maske
aber im endeffekt besser
ab dem ersten oktober sollen die länder
zudem je nach infektions lage weitere
schutzvorgaben anordnen können dazu
zählen masken pflicht in bussen und
bahnen des nahverkehrs sowie in weiteren
öffentlich zugänglichen innenräumen
die länder sollen selbstständig eine
testpflicht in schulen und kitas
verhängen können sogar eine masken
pflicht für schüler ab der fünften
klasse ist möglich wenn die masten
pflicht kommt weil das bei mir geschehen
ist es notwendig macht von den ländern
beschlossen dann kann der test als eine
alternative zur maske gesehen werden die
länder können es aber auch ermöglichen
dass stattdessen eine frische impfung
oder eine fläche genesung geht das
gesetz muss jetzt noch vom bundestag und
bundesrat verabschiedet werden
könnte es theoretisch noch verhindert
werden im bundestag und bundesrat aber
im ernst maske maske maske das ist also
das motto für herbst und winter so
willst die ampel regierung und karl
lauterbach will außerdem wieder impfen
impfen impfen und sorgt allerdings auch
damit für ordentlich verwirrung schon
mal auf seinen auftritt noch einmal den
sie gerade gesehen haben hier in berlin
da hat er jetzt nämlich noch
erstaunliche sätze gesagt dass die ihm
vom deshalb so wichtig sei weil geimpfte
frühe symptome zeigen würden also wenn
du geimpft wirst merkst du schneller
dass die korona hast damit sorgt karl
lauterbach jetzt nochmal für heftige
diskussionen
also bei geimpften ist es so dass man
oft schon symptome hat bevor man
überhaupt ansteckend ist weil die
impfung führt dazu dass sozusagen der
körper sehr schnell reagiert noch wenig
viruslast
und dann erst kommen die wehren und
anstatt wie wir uns lassen wir uns auch
einer der gründe weshalb quasi die für
die impfungen die panne begrenzen weil
sehr häufig sind die leute schon mit
symptomen unterwegs und laden dann auch
zu hause noch bevor sie wirklich
ansteckend sind weil bei demjenigen der
geimpft ist die symptome oft beginnen
bevor die viruslast sehr hoch ist das
ist bei ungunsten ganz anders bei
ungeimpften ist zuerst die videos sehr
hoch und dann kommen die symptome
ich bin total fertig hatte es nicht also
wir halten noch mal fest geimpfte zeigen
wohl schneller symptome bemerken ihre
erkrankungen früher deshalb impfen
lassen der biologe klaus stöger hält das
für völligen quatsch er twittert hier
hat man bestenfalls einiges
durcheinandergebracht wir zeigen in den
tritt hier auch nochmal und er schreibt
auch ohne worte und wir wollen ihn
fragen ob er seine worte wieder gefunden
hat er ist und zugeschaltet herr stöhr
sie betitelt die aussage von karl
lauterbach als quatsch und ohne worte
haben sie ihre sprache wiedergefunden
was stört sie so sehr an dieser aussage
die worte da wieder zu finden ist schon
nicht leicht also ist gibt es auf zwei
ebenen ein problem und als erstes man
versucht ja da die ungeimpften auch
wieder zu disqualifizieren mal hingehen
kann natürlich auch gelesen sein und dem
genesenen status hat auch in dem gesetz
hat man nicht richtig berücksichtigt
dann kann man nur dann als genesen und
die maske nicht wagen in den restaurants
weiter wenn man das 90 tage her es ist
vollständig und verstanden
offensichtlich bayern lauterbach und auf
seinen beratern das den geimpfter einen
guten schutz hat natürlich aber ein
genesener noch einen besseren und
längeren schutz bedeutet
kann man als die summe der
unsinnigkeiten die diese sätze her
beinhalten da kann man wirklich nur
fragen oder das alles herkommt und man
hat auch schon viele andere dinge gehört
ferner macht die partie endet erst in
einem jahrzehnt oder in jahrzehnten die
pandemie hört er dann auf wenn die
nasalen impfstoff wird beim also das ist
eine dumme von dingen da verschlägt
einem die sprache verschlägt haben die
sprache weil wir wir brauchen irgendwie
noch eine erklärung warum das dann
passiert also sitzt ja da wir sehen
diese szene gerade nochmal und erklärt
so wie der papst so ungefähr also das
kommt in dem moment ja man nimmt es ja
irgendwie an und gleichzeitig sagen sie
das ist halt völlig daneben keine ahnung
woher das hat also kränkt sie das auch
in ihrer berufsehre
ja denn bei den großen unterschied
zwischen einem theoretiker von einem der
intel active in die nacht eigenen archiv
passende studien interpretiert und
jemanden der eben aktiv über viele
jahrzehnte praktischer solchen
bekämpfung gemacht hat das ist richtig
dass jemand wer geimpft ist natürlich
weniger viren ausscheidet und auch über
einen kürzeren zeitraum
aber das passt eben in die bekämpfung
nicht hinein weil das natürlich im
einzelfall überhaupt nicht zu sehen ist
es ist ja auch nicht zu berechnen und da
muss man sich altersgruppen
unterschieden den eltern betrifft das
weniger über jüngere häufiger es ist
auch richtig wenn ich sage ich schicke
ein eimer wasser ins meer dann ist das
meer auch verlader kann mir auch niemand
was da sagen aber es ist komplett
irrelevant
und das ist eben diese bemerkung her
aber es gibt auch andere punkte in dem
gesetze die in einem die worte schon
verschlagen war ja das war schon böse
jetzt aber
man merkte die die wut oder die
enttäuschung mit dem mehr daran wir
müssen auch mal über diesen satz
sprechen der von karl lauterbach sandra
ja es ist halt so das hat er gesagt herr
lauterbach auch bei dieser
pressekonferenz zum thema massen pflicht
fb2 pflicht jetzt für alle in den
fliegern außer im regierungsflieger ja
was halten sie von dieser absurden
erklärung von karl lauterbach
ja da gibt es zwei punkte dazu als
erstes fb2 masken für die allgemeinheit
in schlechter als medizinische macht und
das hat man immer noch nicht verstanden
da gibt es in deutschland gute
stellungnahmen der evidenzbasierten
medizin die deutsche gesellschaft für
krankenhaushygiene belegt dass immer
wieder ihre zuschauer werden schleicht
das nicht wissen sollten aber das ist
zum beispiel fünf verschiedene fsg
zweimaster typen gibt größen gibt die
muss man als gesicht anpassen und
schauen sich nochmal um berlin zu können
so oder in der bahn oder in der
straßenbahn oder im bus weg durch die
ffw zweimal gericht ich jemals zu groß
zu klein sind unsinn aufgeschnitten
haben oben der leckage also die ft2 man
sich geben kann sind das zweite ist
flugzeugen und auch in den fernzügen
eine sehr gute klimatisierung hat also
da ist eigentlich der die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass viren
neutralisiert ja noch die filter die
indirekte anlagen eingebaut dann sehr
hoch und den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln legt man die emittierten
normale marken also das passt nicht
zusammen das ist die npd biologische
virologisch seite aber die moralische zu
sozialer seite ist dass man hier mit
zweierlei maßstab die menschen mitnehmen
in den herzen die nämlich jemand mit
wenn ich glaube für mich privilegien in
anspruch nehmen zu können und für andere
ja und wenn man dann halt sagt es ist
halt so also vielleicht kennen sie das
von wenn sie es kindern gegenüber
erklären und die wirklich eine erklärung
haben wollen und dann sagt man kommt das
ist halt jetzt so ja ja das passt aber
hinein schauen wir mal mit dem ton mit
ihm erklären mit diesem professoralen
leerere ton mit dem man dort den
journalisten dann basiswissen versucht
zu erklären was passt ja auch alles
hinein für mich ist das tragisch dass
das gesamtpaket
infektionsschutzgesetz an sich
handwerklich immer noch viele fehler
mängel aufweist und eben auch nicht auf
dem evidenzen weil die kann man in den
schulen und in den kindergärten
und in anderen bereichen immer noch an
laktose massentest fordern wie kann man
dort auch die meisten pflicht einfordern
wie kann man parameter überhaupt nicht
festlegen wann welche maßnahmen in den
dann gelten also das sind eigentlich die
dinge die mich mehr aufregen als die
basken nicht getragen dem
regierungsflieger die leute waren ja
auch getestet aber rundherum ist unklar
was die zielstellung dieser maßnahmen
dann will man alle infektionen
verhindern oder wie man das machen was
antut aber hersteller eine abschluss
frage muss mir noch erlaubt sein sie
sitzen ja auch im expertenrat der
bundesregierung sie könnten daher
gegenwirken gegensteuern hat herr
lauterbach nicht auf sie auf ihre
meinung also ich bin nicht im
expertenrat ich wissen in diesem
sachverständigenausschuss in der
sachverständigenausschuss evaluiert die
maßnahmen oder hatte evaluiert die
maßnahmen in der vergangenheit oder
schaut nicht nach vorne es gibt keine
tagesaktuellen interaktion es gibt auch
keine anfragen dazu also wenn ich mir
das gesetz anschaue habe ich manchmal
den eindruck dass herr lauterbach und
auch der justizminister das unter sich
ausgekungelt haben ohne ihre experten
gefragt wir haben gerade genesen statt
90 tage frisch dem drei monate es sind
doch alle evidenz befreite zahlen auch
die stellungnahmen jetzt wir warten auf
den impfstoff im herbst und der
impfstoff im herbst wird dann wie dem
die ausscheidung bei denen auch impften
reduzieren das sind wunschträume
da muss man nur mal die immunologen
fragen der in deutschland gibt es
ausgezeichnete immunologen ihr könnte
man mal fragen dass wir die können einem
das sehr gut erklären vielleicht aber
man will vielleicht das nicht hören das
passt nicht ins narrativen also ich
hatte eigentlich schon manchmal die
worte man will das nicht hören ihm
fehlen manchmal die worte und zum glück
nicht komplett hier das war knallhart
dekan karl lauterbach am
gesundheitsministerium genauso am
justizminister danke an den virologen
klaus stöhr hierbei bild live
[Musik]